tous décidément depuis quelques temps
l'humoriste jean marie bigard se
retrouvent régulièrement au coeur de
différentes polémiques son franc-parler
son ton provocateur ne semble pas faire
l'unanimité mais que ça plaise ou non
l'humoriste n'a visiblement pas
l'intention de se taire aujourd'hui
c'est un nouveau coup de gueule de jean
marie bigard qui a enflammé internet
en effet l'humoriste accuse france
télévisions de l'avoir blacklisté de
l'émission vivement dimanche présentée
par michel drucker pour des raisons
politiques d'après lui alors qu'il avait
été invité par la production de
l'émission sa venue aurait été annulée
en raison d'ordre qui viendraient de la
direction de la chaîne publique selon
lui le problème serait son engagement
politique aux côtés du forum marcel
campion qui se présente à l'élection du
maire de paris contre anne hidalgo et
d'après jean marie bigard michel drucker
n'auraient pas tenté de lui cacher les
raisons de cette annulation j'ai eu
michel drucker
ce matin il m'a dit je ne pourrais pas
te recevoir dans mon émission parce que
tu es amis avec marcel campion
c'est sur scène hier soir qu'il a décidé
de régler ses comptes et il n'a pas
hésité à s'adresser directement à
delphine ernotte la présidente de france
télévisions c'est un retour à la
dictature
avant guerre ma petite delphine on se
connaît delphine on a vu une coupe de
champagne
un spectacle de michel drucker si c'est
ça si ses baskets a pas de place à
l'olympia delvin chômé une chaise sur la
scène tu m'entends alors jean marie
bigard censuré par france 2 choqués ou
pas choqué jean marie bigard nous arrive
merci
[Applaudissements]
après avant d'aller sellam le mot de la
fin jean marie qui est choqué vraiment
choqué je trouve que c'est un scandale
en fait mais c'est pas ça correspond à
l'époque on fait de toute façon
aujourd'hui jean marie bigard il a pas
d'accord parce que déjà il fait des
blagues des blagues un peu scabreuse
marie drôle
bah oui non mais drôle mais qui font pas
forcément rire tout le monde aujourd'hui
par rapport aux ayatollahs du féminisme
donc déjà là il n'a pas la carte ça va
il est de mauvais goût et là en plus
cela il en rajoute une couche parce que
forcément il dézingue des hommes
politiques en l'occurrence madame
hidalgo
donc voilà il est ce qu'un personnage
audi sulfureux et et voilà il est écarté
et c'est un scandale un choc et oui ah
ouais bah oui parce que jean-marie que
j'adore et on est amis que je plus
aucune case du bien pensant c'est là que
mal il est à l'opposé de tous il dit il
dit ce qu'il pense il fait des blagues
qu'il faut extrêmement drôle voilà on le
taxe de tous deux féminines de gros
dégueulasse à la part c'est tout
l'inversé
c'est un homme qui est classe qui est
généreux et cutanées ou dans la vie et
qui est bien élevé merci merci je pense
que si on devait interdire de plateau
toute personnalité qui a été proche de
près ou de loin d'une personne qui a
fait de la politique en france a viré
personne sur les plateaux il faut
rappeler que jean marie vient il est
très populaire c'est le seul humoriste
qui a rempli un stade de france dont
joue ça très dommage qu'on interdise
honneur alors jean marc et jean michel
jarre michel dabat le seul mode façon je
comprends même pas qu'on puisse pas de
choquer je crains que moss en surface
est plus élevé contre toute forme de
censure
saha croyait qu'une présidente calais
j'espère d'autres chats à fouetter de
fond ces mesures se mêlent d habiter et
cetera quelle qu'elle ferme sa gueule
qu'elle redresse les comptes du service
public et ça sera déjà pas mal quand
jean-marie aux panthers la loi est la
loi et qui le laisse parler alors
nazaire alors on va écouter gilles et
gilles vous êtes le seul pas choqué par
cette mesure
dites nous pourquoi jean marie est
devenu que j'adore est devenu un homme
politique donc révélé un homme politique
il ya des élections municipales
vous avez dit je ne suis pas sur la
liste de marcel campion qui se
présentent ne vous êtes à paris sous à
paris mais vous êtes en soutien je
rappelle que les listes ne sont pas
encore déposé exactement jacques 6.5
personne ne suit aucune les je vais
attendre soigneusement de savoir si vous
allez y figurer sur sa liste n'est en
tout cas vous êtes soutien officiel
wintour moi vous n'avez pas aller dans
une émission de divertissement de
service public
vous êtes devenu un homme paul m6 je
parle pas de mains sans carbure non
parce que vous représentez
fond de train fantôme au jardin des
tuileries chute méfie pas que tu manges
et une barbe à papa paroles doivent
désormais décompté s'est remarié après
tuvalu régime ce que tu lis total et
cino parce qu'à ce moment il n'y aurait
plus aucun artiste avoir une expérience
et quand l artiste de droite à son
soutien officiel
les fruits sont tous se soutenir ces
familles mais tant qu elles mêmes et ont
tué raison c'est de toute façon ce n'est
pas encore le cas mais j'ai raison
déclaré rim était déclarée les personnes
qui vont passer lors d'une émission de
service pourront coller les belles
situerait comme patrick sébastien est
déjà pour elle le summum de la vulgarité
mes gars qui va plus loin que patrick
sébastien se fait donc que pour elle
c'est insupportable c'est surtout
l'hypocrisie
le conte ce conte ce qu'on dit à michel
drucker s'est tu peux pas le prendre
parce que il est un homme politique
aujourd'hui
or la campagne n'est pas déclarée
ouverte il n'est pas officiel il vient
et en tant qu'humoriste donc dit la
vérité dit tu ne peux pas le prendre
parce qu'on ne veut pas que tu le
prennes parce que ça on lui même alors
france doit d un truc de la réponse de
france 2 oui d'abord un l'émission est
enregistrée donc si ils veulent
éventuellement il dit le réparer
politique on pouvait couper et ça
m'étonne de michel qu'effectivement il
dit ça ça m'étonne vraiment michel qu'on
lui dicte nordea challenge michel michel
il est super et nicolas michel après
c'est un mec qui est droit et si on le
savait que sous lui demande la main fait
pas c'est pour ça qu'il a fait n'est sûr
en carrière aussi parce que jean michel
c'est un mec droit il a dit à france
télévisions quelque chose il le fait les
chéris je voulais juste dire un mot
vas-y première première chose en afrique
et avec michel la chaîne qu'on ne
parlerait jamais pas un mot sur marcel
campion que je viens faire la promotion
de monein pjak est ma dernière date
parisienne qui est plein à craquer entre
parenthèses
mais on venait pour le dire il suffit
pas d'être un crack et faut le dire bien
sûr que les autres le sache la raison
une deuxième fois en admettant qu'on
manque à notre parole michel drucker et
moi et qu'on souhaite toutefois à parler
commencer le confions j'ai bien il ya un
montage après et on coud le passage cr
dans tous les cas de figure y avait
aucun risque alors niveau que je prenne
du temps de parole ni pour quoi que ce
soit la censure avait été décidé et
comme j'ai ramené ma gueule je pense
qu'ils s'en revenaient un petit peu en
arrière on va on verra ce qu'ils ont dit
ils ont démenti toute censure à nos
confrères de tv mag et d'odit france
telle explique qu'il n'est pas censuré
car jean marie bigard était samedi
dernier en prime time sur france 2 dans
deux heures de rire et rire c'était
avant même et on a mieux fait de faire
michel drucker sur france 3 dans une
autre émission consacrée à l'humour
bon ça aussi c'est pas sûr mais bien sur
france 2 mi février auprès de michel
drucker qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire
eh ben c'est 10 heures c'est que j'ai
ouvert ma gueule comme quoi des fois
faut ce matin peut bel et bien ils ont
fermé la leur
[Rires]
c'est simplement simplement le match le
match qui s'était engagé était perdue
d'avancé aux rockets ce qu'ils t'ont dit
il tu auras invité par thèmes non non
non non ils voient pas réalité je viens
de lire là dans la coulisse il ya dix
secondes que effectivement j'étais à
nouveau admis j'attende téléphoné à
michel drucker pour dire alors j'ai en
juin par adopter de nouveaux et oui mais
c'est à dire que je suis d'une de
nouveau convié sur le service public
sinon sinon il était battu
ouais tu vois dans toutes les colonnes
donc ils ont fermé leur gueule c'est
plutôt pas mal
ici ils sont allés c'est la même chose
avec patrick sébastien ne s'en souvient
patrick serrés chercher la course mais
louis patrick et l'april à l'est de la
chaîne il l'a lu près donc toi ça
c'était très fort et je lui sais gré
encore d'avoir fait ça il dit la lettre
de de france télévisions qui dit nous
avons appris que vous allez recevoir
l'humoriste jean marie bigard et qu'il
allait faire sans célèbres lâchers de
[ __ ] le sketch préférés des français
dans un sondage il arrive en 1ère de
cession' s'assurer et donc c'est très
drôle il a lu cette ses plaies et qui
disait que je devais passer après 22
heures
ouais mentor étiqueté -18 non dit et moi
j'ai réponses et les - 16 g cette fois
c'est chez but bref 20 18 le ch était le
plus la terre occupée
bc c'est terrible c'est j'ai détecté de
c'est ce que j'ai fait cyril staff et
moi aussi j'ai répondu le lendemain ce
que heureusement moi derrière mon
téléphone il ya eu huit cent mille
personnes et j'ai dit mais quand c'est
fait j'ai vu mots mon ami guy bedos sur
france 3 l'autre jour à 14h30 presse qui
faisait ça
le les [ __ ] 75 fois le mot [ __ ]
il est prématuré et j'ai ce qu'ils ont
fait tous fermer leur gueule
ils sont repassés la patate chaude le
csa dit c'est pas nous la chaîne a dit
c'est pas nous et à la fin
officiellement nous a dit faites comme
vous voulez alors et donc j'ai raconté
le sketch où il ya une seule fois le mot
[ __ ] que j'ai remplacé par un sifflet
non j'ai dit c'est fait a lâché 2 7l
l'élevage parce que tout le reste c'est
des termes de chasseurs pêcheurs
alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs choqués après joggé
choqué ce sont les voix la ceinture